Kemba we know you had a lot of hugs to
give Gordon was just giving you some
high praise
what a day physically emotionally
mentally you got anything left in there
I'm good man it was it was an amazing
amazing night amazing day a lot of love
from the fans the organization she's
really good to be back what was it like
the moment that they played the tribute
video and you saw the fans rise to their
feet I know that I saw a lot of emotion
inside of you coming out in that moment
I was trying to hold it in I told myself
I wasn't gonna cry but I could hold it
in there it was it was an amazing video
no I knew it was gonna be a video but I
just didn't know what to expect but um
yeah it was amazing question is does he
have as good of dance moves as his mom
does because we showed her a couple
times of the stairs which is pretty good
have you seen that yet I haven't seen
Gordon how would you describe sort of
the the easy pickup in the chemistry
that Kem has had with the Celtics team
start really in the season I mean he's
such a great player so he's easy to play
with you can get to the teeth of the
defense create his own shot grading for
others when we play it with pace and
space we're tough to guard we got to
keep doing that Gordon congratulations
on the win and Kevin congratulations on
a great trip back good job Ali and Kemba
Walker ready to carry this franchise at
the weight of the franchise on his
shoulders doesn't feel that in Boston
but he is a Maine caught they are strong
and they are six and one and the Celtics
of won six in a row